hello welcome back to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hunger to be Tuesday
at two p.m. pacific right here on
gamespot com I'm your host Daniel to our
how you doing it's been a while that III
thing happened then we took a week off
it turns out not much happened in the
world of video games anyway unless
you're a destiny fat which is why we've
got Eric Tay and Alex new house to fans
of destiny Eric lovely see wearing a
shirt today I thinks it must have known
you were coming on and talk bad all the
stuff to tap in with destiny and there's
been a lot of stuff happening over the
past couple weeks there was that whole
collector's edition for our there was
the the backlash to the eurogamer
interview at e3 and now as it turns out
if you're a fan of red bull they've got
something for you there as well and you
two guys have like different perspective
on a lot of this stuff first of all how
much destiny have you guys actually
played Eric how many characters do you
have I have 334 I think just finished
that so I have a lot of hours I don't
wanna talk about it I was like wow you
don't want to know you never look at how
many times in la porte / played yeah you
don't do that figured out right Alex
what about you I have won 34 and 131
okay not as much as him still over 120
hours playing destiny so from that I can
calculate you probably done all right
it's been a while fair enough and so
you're obviously big fans of the game
both of you at differing opinions on
let's say the collectors edition thing
first of all so Alex what's your take on
what they don't suffer for those who
don't know what what happened with this
one talk about the pricing and and have
it eventually ended up coming out so
when bungee the developer of does me
announced their new expansion for the
game they said that you know they're
going to sell this expansion in two
different forms first you can buy it
standalone or you can buy it in like a
pack that comes with the game the first
two expansions and the new expansion
it's kind of in par for the course yeah
and so one of the so you could also get
the collector's edition which is the
that bundle with some extra stuff and
that that extra stuff is the problem
here that extra stuff was originally
exclusive to the collectors edition you
got to pay 80 bucks to get you know both
the the base game and the three
expansions and then also to get those
in-game items and so players who already
have had you know I've already been
playing destiny like Eric and I we were
pretty frustrated about that we wanted
endgame items we thought that we should
be able to get those without having to
pay 80 bucks for the the base game ok
are young yeah and front two expansion
packs presumably had already bought yeah
and then they're taking in King which I
guess you guys will be purchasing and so
the backlash was that you were
essentially having to dump 80 bucks to
get that sort of that little piece of
content as well obviously as the taken
King and everything else so this away
bungee clearly are trying to like get
people up to speed like new car new
players into the game so the eventual I
guess end to this story or as we have it
now is that you can i just buy that for
20 career around yeah so you can buy the
new expansion for 40 bucks and then you
can also pay an additional twenty
dollars to get that like a pack of all
that content which is three emotes three
class items and three shaders alright so
Tay what what are those pieces of
content are they like gameplay changing
are they are they chose their vanity
purely vanity I would say maybe you can
argue that the class armor is the way
they work now is they give you slight
bonuses to leveling up your gun faster
but that kind of stuff doesn't influence
or affect the gameplay and that's the
biggest thing for me like because like
people will say oh it's like a micro
transaction almost yeah kind of like but
you spending the extra twenty bucks it's
like maybe you think you look cooler but
at the end of the day it's like that's
about it like they're not you're not
gaining any type of like power or like
some type of lead I had a weapon yeah
you're not giving anything too crazy I
think the collector is like the hard
copy one does have some guns in it but
it's not going to be better like that
much better than anything else they're
all pretty like similar so so you're
kind of okay of it you're like holy okay
that's it youryour it's not like
Stockholm Syndrome where you got that
it's why it's it's it's just vanity
stuff it sits on the face it's it's like
getting skins for my character exact
dodecyl yeah I think League of Legends
mean I I definitely had more of a
problem when it was eighty dollars yeah
like for everything because then it kind
of like I get why everyone's mad it's
like oh so I guess everything we bought
before was like twenty bucks yeah worth
you know in theory but not like the
moment it happened I told Alex I was
like oh we're getting a fifty percent
off now its twenty bucks I'll totally
I'll poly buy it like but but that's me
like I'm willing to spend the twenty
bucks for those shaders and stuff like
that not everybody's like that but again
it doesn't affect the game so whatever
so Alex you obviously don't agree with
ya
so I actually look at this differently
the way I look at it does you know the
pact that they were selling for 80 bucks
with the base game in the three
expansions and all these items you can
break it up now basically into okay the
the taken King expansion is being sold
for forty dollars okay the base game in
the first two expansions are now being
sold for twenty because you have that
extra pack also for twenty would you
complain yeah so you know what what Eric
just hinted at is like now I feel like
my previous purchases that I've already
spent a hundred bucks on is now just
valued at twenty dollars in this you
know I understand you know having been a
day one player that games are going to
depreciate in value but Destiny's a
unique situation and that is still very
active game and yeah you know still has
a huge player base and I'm obviously
still supporting it's less than a year
old yeah exactly so I you know as a
player who's put over a hundred twenty
hours in this game I want to feel like
my value is being recognized by Bungie I
want to feel like you know bungee is
recognizing me as a person who's
dedicated my time to this and them
saying that they expect us to still pay
twenty bucks for this in-game content
and then that they're acquitting that
content value eyes with the original
based game and the first two expansions
seems a bit ridiculous to me so is this
a problem for you guys going forward as
fairies because presumably you know they
said this is their ten-year game they're
going to keep doing this horribly signal
destiny to will eventually come out and
they'll they'll do the same thing for
you guys like obviously a lot of people
you know sit six months off of the new
release schedule so they can save a
bunch of cash on games and still have a
good time is that possible if your
destiny pair can you just not buy into
this stuff day one and still have a good
time or are you kind of locked into
their content release because the
problem definitely had at the start was
that there wasn't really that much stuff
to do which is why people are so thirsty
for these expansion packs so like Eric
do you think like you have an option not
to buy this stuff or is that really if
you're a real destiny player you sort of
locked in you like have to do it kind of
like world at war crime yeah I think if
you're playing destiny and you're
consistently playing destiny is hard to
not buy the new content because like you
said we're start like we're kind of
starving for the content because like
even with house of wolves as we had
discussed before I'm like yeah it's
probably my last good four ish weeks
maybe six weeks and it's kind of done
that like I've dropped off again i still
play once or twice a week because of my
friends i might play a little bit more
just but less right yeah and so
basically it's just like well when
the next one coming up now everyone's
juiced because in two months I'll get to
play taking king and that should
supposedly be a little bit bigger than
just a normal DLC expansion pack but who
knows how much bigger but they're making
it seem at least like within on like you
know somewhere in that territory of one
to two or maybe two if we're lucky but
um yeah we have like you just kind of
have to buy into it if you want it but
if you're more casual Bungie has done a
good job in the sense that they do let
players that don't buy into it still
kind of participate in small ways kind
of like to get you to want to buy it
right like they leave all these little
red combs of like oh here why don't you
participate in these like little events
and then kind of hope that that sparks
you into buying the next piece of
content does it split the user base
though do you think like that there
there's content and obviously like high
level players who are playing with their
buddies will want to play and then
you're like if Alex it's like you know
whoever you ride with like to your
friends whatever decided like they were
going to get the pact you'd feel
compelled to get it as well right yeah
play with them anymore yeah definitely
and I think Erik's totally right you do
feel compelled if you're a consistent
player of Destiny to buy the content and
I actually think that results in a less
split player base than other games that
have you know DLC drops because it is
such in a lot of ways that did such an
essential part of the Destiny experience
to have that extra content and you know
this is another reason why I don't
really like what they're doing with the
the twenty-dollar pack of endgame
content is you know because there they
are in a sense bundling all of that
original content together in a 60 door
for a 60 bucks secure our price which to
me seems like the better like that is
clearly the better deal here like you're
getting like one of the big criticisms
of Destiny was that it was kind of you
know like I'm mountain people are
starved for continent and so by bundling
all that together you actually have an
experience that is worth it but then you
know bungees still saying to players who
have been paying for it along the way
that hey we know that you love destiny
so we're going to give you this option
that we know you're going to buy because
you want that content anyways and so
you're going to pay that twenty dollars
for that so it's going to continue to be
a problem because like okay both of you
clearly love it like you've paid 130
hours and change God knows I'm like you
probably like 300 hours or something
like that getting right now sir clearly
like if we're going to talk
but this is a value proposition you guys
probably feel like you've gotten value
out of it but if we like break it down
so what destiny original game I'm really
$60 the first expansion pack 20 they're
both 20 unless you bought the season
pass which then made it 35 35 okay so
let's for the sake of argument will say
100 bucks for the two of them right then
to taking Kings another 40 40 bucks so
that means in the first year going to
spend the one hundred and forty dollars
I'm like Activision could be learnt this
from World of Warcraft and what Blizzard
is one that they merged and they ended
up like being involved this business
partners but like burning crusade was 40
bucks he came at I think two years after
the release of i was at 06 and man like
whole new area like flying man's the
battleground stuff they added two new
races like you guys feel like you're
being nickeled and dimed on distance so
the difference is like you bring up a
good point like you look at the overall
cost of like destiny for the whole year
assuming you by taking king but i look
at it too is like okay if you bought wow
and you play for a year guess what
you're still spending over one hundred
forty dollars because it remember it's a
subscription game so it's sixty dollars
and fifteen dollars a month so at the
end of the day if you're one year wow is
still more expensive than my one year
destiny yeah and i granted yes you're
right though in terms of like the like
the world like world of warcraft is
bigger but it's set because it's an
MMORPG anyone who thinks destiny is an
MMORPG is crazy it has elements of that
but like for me like you said value wise
like I've gotten my bang for my buck out
of it and like again I just want to
reiterate that the twenty dollars nobody
has to spend that twenty dollars on it
it's just there for them but yeah I mean
this is also where I differ from
American that I'm coming from at this
from like I'm more of like a first
person shooter perspective where I'm
used to getting a sixty-dollar
experience that is you know cohesive
that is there's a lot of bang for your
buck in that package and so coming to
this where it's more like a platform or
the building upon it every couple months
and you're expected to pay for that more
like an MMO I'm very unused to that and
I'm very very much feel like I'm being
nickeled and dimed a lot of the time and
the nature of Destiny's is that because
you're starved for content you're always
looking for more content even if that
content comes in the form of emails nuh
shaders right I'm so different to though
like because like yes you come from a
like a halo background rule
like they're dlc is like oh here's new
multiplayer maps where's with destiny
it's like here's new multiplayer but
here's new single-player contact in Halo
you never felt like like destiny like
just [ __ ] nothing going down after
time like it's great that you're playing
with all your buddies but you are
replaying the same stuff from like I'm
not Eric I can't really speak to but
just like listening to you guys talking
about it seems like there's a lot of
repetition whereas when even we were
playing a hail of like three a year
later there's so much [ __ ] in that game
we're so much to do that you kind of
didn't really feel repetitive at
anything exactly and that's why you see
people you know at e3 for example going
crazy for the armor shooter they were
getting out there is because anything
that's new in that game is so coveted
that it drives people to pay money for
things that otherwise and other games
they probably wouldn't and that's the
biggest problem I have with this Eric to
change in the tide of games it's just
academic i prefer work yeah better for
worse like I understand it I get it I
can also understand why people are upset
about it and like there's frustrations
with it obviously but that's just kind
of the trend of where games are going
right now it's all like can we make a
good decent solid foundation of a game
and then how do we get more money out of
people and like sadly that's just where
it is it's just are you gonna spend the
money or not like you don't have to you
know at the end of the day if you enjoy
playing it and you get your value out of
it like I do then it's great right but
it's not for everybody like I get it I
totally understand it's a divisive issue
I think this is their 10-year plan then
we're probably going to be talking about
this for quite a while and the next come
in the coming years let us know what you
think of course in the comments below do
you play destiny have you spent 140 or a
hundred dollars and willing to spend
another 40 bucks or do you feel like
it'd be nickeled and dimed by Activision
as well I let us know below
you